alright it was a pretty good week so far
for the gays that's right the supreme
court let stand 5 federal appellate
court rulings so a bunch more states are
getting gay marriage Utah Oklahoma
Virginia Wisconsin and Indiana so we've
got an updated gay marriage map all
right there you go dark blue fully legal
uh and the light blue are the new states
and uh the gray they like that
traditional old-fashioned marriage you
guys want to comment on the lab and a
harem yeah yeah exactly anything else
interesting you find anything
interesting gays like water apparently
every day those two water acceptable if
you're gonna you can have like super
conservatives like to one side of you
don't be surrounded by them ideally yeah
not much surprising about that map I
mean New Mexico possibly that's pretty
much it that's in terms of the
long-established ones okay so the
interesting thing I think about this is
CNN's Jeffrey Toobin who's their chief
legal analyst he basically said that the
Supreme Court did not do their duty by
not hearing this case because that's
what would have led to all the states in
the Union getting gay marriage but don't
let me speak for him let's listen it
well you know this is why we have a
Supreme Court right to settle
complicated controversial legal issues
frankly I think it's outrageous that the
court didn't take this case I mean you
know the way the court works is it takes
four votes to agree to hear a case it's
five votes to reach a judgment but four
votes to hear a case and apparently
there were not four votes to take these
cases now the justices may say though
they don't explain these rulings look
there's no controversy in the in the
courts of appeals now they have all
ruled that same-sex marriages the law we
don't need to settle a disagreement
there could be some strategic voting
going on on the part of some of the
justices saying we don't want to take
this case because our side may lose
that's in something that goes on but
frankly I think this was a real
abdication of duty on the part of the
Supreme really the discussion about
same-sex marriage has been going on in
this country for quite some time and the
kind used me and the country has changed
so much
and there are so many states that have
it now that you know yes the the court
shouldn't get ahead of the public but
you know the public is you know now all
the polls show a majority favored
same-sex marriage it's a place where uh
it seems to me it's past time for the
Supreme Court to step in but you know
what I don't get a vote okay so so I
think that's really interesting what
he's saying they're so yes we got some
more gay marriage that's pretty good
most people are down with that but that
the Court itself didn't really do what
its duty is um this seems this seems
kind of shitty like when I saw
originally on Twitter when I saw it
rolling in I was like aw this is all
good all good we're getting more states
are coming around but ultimately isn't
this exactly what the Supreme Court is
supposed to do aren't they supposed to
take the challenging cases they
literally legally abided by what they
were supposed to do and he's like well
this is right I'm with the anchor
Michaela Pereira like really you think
this is outrageous in a legal abdication
which shouldn't they are they supposed
to take this the tough cases and when
something is being talked about
nationally as this has been going on
long enough aren't they supposed to jump
in and say this is what the law of the
land is I think Toob Toob is mostly
historically accurate there in that when
you have two different sets of laws like
you're treating one group of people two
different ways in different states
they're supposed to step in but not is
not especially the way it is right now
it's not so much that the laws are
different different states generally
historically when it's a seriously
contentious social issue the Supreme
Court will step in not when the laws are
different but when different like a
different district judges and things
like that a ruling differently like if
you had a Supreme Court up a same-sex
marriage ban knock down in one state and
then upheld by a district court and then
in a different state it struck down by
district court usually when there's
judicial disagreement that's when a step
supreme court stuff in it almost enough
to that though that's but I don't like
in in all these cases that we were
talking about that they might have
picked up it was basically that the the
law was saying you can't have same-sex
marriage and then the the the judiciary
was saying you can there seem to be
pretty widespread agreement by the
judges in terms of what the law should
be and so that might not have been
contentious enough judicial if the
Supreme Court field at a step in right
so as I assume both of you are for
same-sex marriage wouldn't you want the
court to do this we're forgetting the
legal whether they technically legally
had to do it or whether it was okay when
you want them to step up and do
something that would just get this issue
off the table isn't it are you sick of
talking about it it has been a long time
but you know I do agree that we need to
do with legally proper because I stand
by uh keeping our legal system legal in
and buy the book rather than just you
know my religion says this and my
feelings say that yeah I look I I think
whatever allows it to be the law of the
land would be good but I would say that
if you think that in five or ten years
it's going to be effectively wide across
the entire country which then D which is
probably gonna be the case I think the
best possible way would be for people's
opinions to change and then the laws to
be changed as opposed to being mandated
by the Supreme Court which could in the
case of like roe v wade could lead to
long-standing resentment by the people
who feel like they ruled the wrong way I
would rather that it was a popular
decision and it's moving so fast I i saw
a chart today I think on Vox it compared
approval rates for same-sex marriage
historically versus at Inter interracial
marriage about three decades after it
was legally up but legally allowed
you're able to have interracial marriage
for to reach majority approval in the
case of same-sex marriage its reach
majority approval even before it's legal
yes so it is happening quickly to me
what this more is about is of course I
I'm happy with what happened here uh and
I guess maybe I'm not as patient as what
you're saying which i think is a
legitimate point but it seems to me it
just shows how broken our system is like
right now we're at war in Syria Congress
didn't vote for it we have branches of
government that are supposed to do
different things so Congress didn't vote
on us going to a new country to attack
and forget attacking Iraq again that's
fine uh and here the Supreme Court is
not I just don't see them doing what
they're supposed to do despite pretty I
mean that's a pretty sound argument that
I think you're making yeah well look if
your argument is that the system is
broken you then have widespread across
building with you
yeah um do you think the gay marriage
thing is over i really believe i've been
saying it for a while the show that the
republicans are actually gonna be for it
in 2016 whoever runs we've been watching
uh you know conservative candidates and
people in office you know slowly
migrated their views this way as the
popular opinion moves this way which
makes me think maybe you don't care and
you just want the votes and you're doing
what's popular and if if that's what it
takes fine let it be a good officials
only doing something cuz it's Popular's
and that bizarre will actually speak to
that I mean Ted Cruz really is the only
person in the Republican Party who
really came out against this so does
that shows that the Republicans are
really coming around yeah I think I
think that even he will back off I mean
traditionally when you have an issue
like this being pushed by one party it's
either because they think they can make
a lot of money off of it or they can
move a lot of votes by it historically
same-sex marriage has never been an
absolutely massive fundraising tool for
the Republicans in the way that like
abortion rights are something like that
and that there's so much overlap in
terms of the people who oppose same-sex
marriage with other traditionally more
lucrative issues like abortion why not
just move them on that issue and and and
not risk turning off some moderate
Republicans who might be in favor of
same-sex marriage all right there you go
call me crazy I'm for gay marriage and
also for a functional system i know
that's nuts but you know what can i say
i'm a dreamer